there's so many things happening out
here this week in Los Angeles Paulie
goes uh you know I had some guys who
lost it got lost a bowling league it was
an all Greek bowling league and the
loser has to get a haircut like fritzy's
and I said okay so they just came in if
you were watching the live look in the
guy got a fritzy there and Reggie jumped
in you know giving him a haircut as well
yes Polly
so this Greek bowling league every year
they get together these buddies and
that's the Greek bowling league and they
have to get a punishment when they lose
and they created this new haircut called
a frizzy and that the thing is the guy
who lost his name vas and vas has great
hair like Patrick Dempsey's type and he
just got a weed whack by Reggie Miller
but you guys were doing it all wrong
you're gonna give I was terrible but I
like how the punishment was what fritzy
has the fritzy
he's Reggie Miller the hall-of-famer
he's gonna be doing the Western
Conference Finals with Marv on TNT Game
three is Sunday at 8:00 Eastern before
the break I mentioned a couple things
let me start with Jeff hornacek being
hired as the Knicks head coach what does
this mean because Phil goes out of that
Laker fraternity well it's interesting
because everyone assumed it was going to
be someone with triangle experience and
Jeff hornacek does not have that I'm
sure a lot of people are scratching
their head at the hire because he came
out of nowhere
usually you were thinking Thibodeau who
had already had gone to Minnesota
resigned Kurt Rambis Luke before he got
the Laker job but out of left field here
comes coach hornacek and maybe he can
institute some of his own philosophies
not a lot of experience there obviously
he was at the helm with with Phoenix
well not great success but I think it's
a solid hire but is he gonna have to run
the triangle I hope not that the
triangle is it's it's past its time in
it Ranch you've got to have the right
player but even
day in today's game let's say phil was
coaching now and he had Kobe or he had
Michael would he be running this style
of offense yes even in today's game if
you have Kobe if you have Scottie
Michael Shaq yes you can run that
offense if he was coaching today and he
had the Golden State Warriors would he
be running the track or this or this San
Antonio Spurs yes because you have those
type of players you have bigs that can
pass that can shoot and that said great
screens
yes and you have playmakers in curry and
and Thompson yes he could run it with
those team but can you can you still
shoot the three in the Triangle like
that because I know that you would have
current Paxson shooting threes or Craig
Hodges but but they shoot threes in
transition right it was different with
the Bulls well a little bit different
with the Lakers but if you remember Rick
Fox Glen Rice their first championship
in 2000 he had three-point shooters on
the floor for that spacing for Kobe and
for Shaq Robert Horry and Robert Horry
you know yeah I mean obviously threes
are being shot more at a premium now but
with those two teams he could run the
try and go with right of the final four
teams let's say you're 35 mm-hmm still
in good shape sir who what team would
you want to play for no question I know
the easy answer everyone's gonna think
I'm good I would say it would be Golden
State yeah no I would want to play with
LeBron James and the Cleveland Cavaliers
because all I would have to do is put my
camper and backpack on and chill out
either in the the short 3-point corner
or at the top of the key
I wouldn't have to do anything and I
would be spoon-fed by the King feed me
grapes er feed me grapes yes why is the
corner three shorter I don't know like
the people are surprised when I say that
that you know you should shoot from the
corner because it's a shorter three and
they go late isn't it a standard three
and I go no is it tougher in the corner
I don't think so it's I mean like a free
throw to me the the hardest three would
probably be like that the 45-degree
three is probably the toughest three top
of the key and corners I thought that's
easier there's an article out today that
I just did from a writer for The New
Yorker you could look it up and the the
writers name is Charles bathia
and he was trying to propose to me he
talked to Larry legend as well I thought
should there be a four-point play and I
told him we would be the laughingstock
of all the major leagues
if the league is really considering
adding a four-point play because what
we're really talking about is one player
one player really has range in today's
game and that would be curry
maybe Damian Lillard has you know that
kind of range but to add a four-point
play for one guy I think would be
absolutely ridiculous and I know he
spoke with Larry legend and Larry legend
said the three came along in 1979 his
rookie season and he kind of adapted to
it if we bring in right now young kids
are looking at Steph Curry say that's
all I want to do people don't understand
that is as great as Steph is that
three-point shooting sets up everything
else of a game the floater
the runner the left and right drives
it's great because that's all we see on
SportsCenter is his highlights of him
shooting threes but why not make the
three a little bit deeper such as right
now it's almost 24 feet yeah it would
make it 27 no make it you could add
another foot and a half to it what's
being lost is the mid-range yes but now
I bring it back if I extend the three
now I have the mid-range jumper that
comes back into style would be full
don't wanna leave it more in favor of
that you're not have a four-point play
yeah Paulie what do you have Reggie Bird
said it's a nice combo Larry Bird told
The New Yorker that they didn't even
practice threes when they played it was
like a waste of time because they didn't
take that money he said it he doubts
there could be a four point line but if
you put one in ten years from now kids
would be good at it he goes if you put a
28-foot shot that was tough a
four-pointer can think about that 20
you're gonna have kids no no he lost is
the 15 footer
18-footer the 12-footer but that's not
entertainment that's not it's not but
it's a lost art in today's game but the
reason why people are watching is
because of the three and the similar
dial yeah that you once scored you used
to have games that were 118 113 now when
we look at again a Golden State does
this but it's rare when you see these
teams putting up a hundred at the end of
the day it's all about entertainment yes
and getting people obviously in your
building in your arena and to have them
entertaining shooting threes and having
Steph Curry score 15 points in less than
two minutes that's entertainment you'd
want to see that but I just think to be
well-rounded as a basketball player your
mid-range game is being lost in today's
game but if you're the commissioner
people are watching Golden State Golden
State plays you know yes no matter
demographics age it doesn't matter
everybody is curious interested they
like that aside from that I don't think
people are curious about the NBA you
know that there's still the LeBron
factor whether you're rooting for him or
against him but right I find Oklahoma
City fascinating because of Westbrook
and Durant but Golden State is must-see
TV you don't have enough of that in the
NBA and I think that's where the style
might bring more people in that they'll
go yeah I'll watch a Memphis Atlanta
game because they're gonna put up some
points well let's look at how Golden
State was constructed by Bob Myers and
Jerry West you got draymond Green a
four-year college player at Michigan
State
you've got curry who went three years at
David a then three years for klay
Thompson at Washington State Bogut comes
over from Australia so you've got guys
that have the fundamentals they're not
one and done type players and they've
got players like Andre Iguodala who was
on losing teams before will do whatever
it takes to win so if you're a president
or general manager you've got to look at
guys that are willing to sacrifice for
your teams to be successful Leandro
Barbosa was a star six
an award-winner comes in plays his role
so you got to have guys that understand
what's it gonna take for us to be
successful yeah I think it's it's like
the NFL that everybody throws for at
least 4,000 yards well and didn't that
start with the st. Louis Rams the best
show on turf and everyone tried to
emulate their teams after that right and
it took a while right
because you couldn't do it right away
correct and then now everybody you had
to have a Marshall Faulk and you had the
order and Kurt Warner Isaac hold there
Isaac Isaac and Isaac Bruce and Tori
hold for hold yes you got game you had
to have that type of personnel to catch
up to the Golden State Warriors there's
only one dream on but how long does it
take for everybody else to catch up to
what Golden State's doing well you're
gonna find the type of player like curry
so I can have a system like the Rams
head but you it's different though cuz I
think any NFL team can sort of run with
the Patriots do not as well but
everybody throws for 5,000 yards and
puts up those numbers you can't recreate
Golden State's style with any other team
in the image you can't recreate it but
you can get close and look at the
Portland Trailblazers who face them in
the second round
well Damian Lillard was averaging 30
points against Portland he's as close to
Steph Curry's gonna get CJ McCollum was
going toe to toe with clay Thompson now
Amina was shooting threes like yeah like
draymond Green he's not the defender or
can handle the basketball like like
money Green so you can see there are
some teams that are trying to base their
formula off the success of Golden State
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you